Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
NOW, WHO'S READY TO TRY
THE CUP OF THE FUTURE?
[ Voice breaking ]
THIS IS MY PASSION.
THIS IS MY DESTINY.
I'M SUPPOSED TO BE HERE.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
WHAT?
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
BRACE YOURSELVES.
I'M ABOUT TO BLOW YOUR MINDS.
WELL, THAT BLACK-BEAN STUFF
IS THE [BLEEP]
Narrator:
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I CAN ACTUALLY
MAKE THIS WORK.
WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO PARTNER
WITH HIM?
BUT IT'S GONNA TAKE SOMEONE
WHO HAS THE VISION TO SEE.
YOU KNOW I'M STILL IN,
RIGHT?
OH.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
I DON'T NEED SOMEONE
TO HOLD MY HAND. I CAN DO THIS.
YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE UP
THIS CRYING STUFF.
THE MINUTE A WOMAN CRIES,
YOU'RE GIVING AWAY YOUR POWER.
WHAT'S
YOUR SECURITY BACKGROUND?
BE CAREFUL
WHEN YOU ANSWER THIS,
'CAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE ABOUT TO GET FRIED.
UH-OH!
WE DO NOT HAVE
A TECHNOLOGY BACKGROUND.
OH, GOD.
I NEVER HAVE MET
A MORE NAIVE PERSON.
I'M PREPARING THE BUTTER
TO SAUTé YOU IN.
OH, STOP IT!
GIVE THEM A CHANCE.
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND.
I MEAN, TRUST ME.
I DON'T TRUST YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT? THERE ARE HACKERS
OUT THERE GOING, "YEAH, BOY!"
YOU WERE REALLY RUDE
TO THEM.
IT WAS NOT RUDE.
SHAME ON BOTH OF YOU.
BOOM GOES THE DYNAMITE!
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
♪♪
Narrator:
FIRST INTO THE TANK IS A TWIST
ON A CLASSIC
MIDDLE EASTERN FAVORITE.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS JESSE WOLFE.
I'M A UCF STUDENT
FROM ORLANDO, FLORIDA,
AND MY COMPANY IS O'DANG HUMMUS.
TODAY, WE ARE SEEKING $50,000
FOR 10% EQUITY STAKE
IN MY HUMMUS EMPIRE.
HUMMUS -- IT IS A DISH
THAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ENJOYING
FOR YEARS --
900 YEARS, TO BE EXACT.
THIS ANCIENT DISH IS HANDCRAFTED
WITH CHICKPEAS, LEMON JUICE,
AND, OF COURSE, GARLIC,
RIGHT?
MMM.
BUT, UNFORTUNATELY,
THE FLAVORS ARE BEYOND EXPIRED.
SAY HELLO TO O'DANG HUMMUS.
WE MAKE THE MOST DELICIOUS,
BEST-DANG HUMMUS YOU'VE EVER HAD
AND ABSOLUTELY REFUSE TO DO ANY
OF THOSE TRADITIONAL FLAVORS.
INSTEAD, WE PUT THE "FUN"
IN "DYSFUNCTIONAL"
WITH WILD AND CRAZY FLAVORS
THAT TAKE YOUR TASTE BUDS
ON A JOYRIDE TO FLAVOR TOWN.
[ LAUGHS ]
O'DANG IS ONLY 30 CALORIES
ON AVERAGE PER SERVING.
THAT'S APPROXIMATELY
1/3 THE CALORIES
OF SOME STORE-BOUGHT HUMMUS,
WHICH MEANS
YOU CAN EAT THREE TIMES AS MUCH.
BOOM GOES THE DYNAMITE!
[ LAUGHS ]
SO CHOMP, CHOMP.
WHO WANTS A SNACK?
BRING IT ON.
WE DO.
LET'S DO IT, GUYS.
YEAH, LET'S TRY IT.
ONE FOR YOU, SIR.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
AW, THANK YOU.
HE'S SUCH A GENTLEMAN ALWAYS.
OH, HE IS
A TRUE GENTLEMAN.
FOR YOU,
MR. WONDERFUL.
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'LL DO THE SAME FOR BARB,
BECAUSE I AM MR. WONDERFUL.
WHY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[ LAUGHS ]
ONE FOR YOU, MR. CUBAN.
THANK YOU, SIR.
JESSE, WHAT ARE THE FLAVORS
WE'RE TRYING?
THE GREEN ONE IS
OUR DILLIONAIRE DILL PICKLE.
YEAH!
THE BLACK ONE IN THE MIDDLE
IS OUR SWEET & SPICY BLACK BEAN.
WE TOOK
ALL THE CHICKPEAS OUT,
AND WE PUT
A WHOLE DIFFERENT BEAN IN.
THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
IT'S GOOD, RIGHT?
IT'S SUPER-CREAMY.
YEAH.
THAT ONE'S REALLY GOOD.
WE WANT TO BREAK DOWN
THE ETHNIC BARRIER OF HUMMUS.
SABRA'S THE BIG, YOU KNOW,
GUY IN THE MARKET,
WITH OVER, YOU KNOW, 64%
OF THE MARKET SHARE,
AND THEY DO
THE TRADITIONAL FLAVORS.
YOU'RE A HEALTHIER-FLAVORED
HUMMUS.
THE CHALLENGE IS,
IT'S IN THE REFRIGERATED
PART OF MOST STORES.
ARE YOU READY FOR THIS?
OKAY.
OKAY, I'M ABOUT TO BLOW
YOUR MIND. BRACE YOURSELVES.
OH, NO.
SO, YOU'RE RIGHT.
WE ARE BRINGING OUT
A NEW PRODUCT WHICH
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON.
WHAT IS IT?
THIS IS
A HUMMUS SALAD DRESSING.
SO, THESE ARE REALLY COOL.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA BE BOTTLED,
WHICH MEANS THEY'RE SHELF-STABLE
FOR TWO YEARS.
TWO YEARS?
YEAH.
THIS IS A RANCH ON RANCH.
THIS IS
OUR BUFFALO WING DRESSING.
AND, THEN,
THIS IS OUR HUMMY MUSTARD,
OUR TAKE
OF A HONEY MUSTARD.
YEAH, SO YOU'RE
MORE THAN WELCOME TO TRY THAT.
AND WHAT'S GREAT
ABOUT THOSE SALAD DRESSINGS,
NOT ONLY ARE THEY
SHELF-STABLE --
OKAY.
THAT'S REALLY GOOD.
YOU LIKE IT?
ARE YOU READY FOR THIS?
IS IT GONNA
BLOW MY MIND?
YEAH -- OIL-FREE.
WHAT?!
AND WE'VE SHOWED THEM
TO BIG RETAILERS,
AND THEY ARE GOING NUTS
OVER THEM.
GOING NUTS LIKE
WRITING YOU A PURCHASE ORDER?
SO, WE ARE GOING BACK
WITH OUR SECOND MEETING
WITH PUBLIX GROCERY STORE.
WE'RE GOING BACK
FOR 1,100 GROCERY STORES
IN TWO WEEKS
TO FINALIZE THAT DEAL.
SO,
IF THIS ALL WORKS OUT,
WHAT WILL SALES BE
IN THIS CALENDAR YEAR?
THIS CALENDAR YEAR,
$1.3 MILLION.
AND WHAT ARE THEY HERE,
JUST UP TO DATE?
HOW MANY TO DATE?
WE JUST STARTED
OFFICIALLY SELLING.
SO, HERE'S
WHAT HAPPENED --
SO YOU HAVE NO SALES
RIGHT NOW?
NO, WE ACCIDENTALLY SOLD
$70,000 IN PRODUCTS.
IT'S CONFUSING.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
SO, HERE'S WHAT I DID.
I ENTERED A COUPLE
BUSINESS PLANS AT MY COLLEGE.
IT WAS NOTHING MORE THAN A TEST
13 MONTHS AGO.
WE HAVE
A BUNCH OF FARMERS MARKETS.
I JUST WANTED TO PROVE
THAT THERE WAS A DEMAND.
NOW, IT TOOK OFF
LIKE A FREAKIN' ROCKET.
WE BECAME
AN ORLANDO SENSATION.
WE WERE IN 10 FARMERS MARKETS
WITHIN 3 MONTHS,
AND I STEPPED BACK, AND I SAID,
"I CAN DO IT AT GROCERY STORES."
WHAT WERE YOU
SELLING THEM FOR?
$5 A TUB
FOR AN 8-OUNCE TUB.
$5 A TUB.
WHEN YOU GET INTO
PUBLIX'S 1,100 STORES --
WHICH IS INTERESTING,
OKAY?
YEAH.
IF HE GETS IN.
IF YOU GET IN, WHY WOULD
THEY ROLL OUT 1,100 STORES
WITHOUT TESTING IT
IN 10?
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED
WITH PUBLIX.
WE SIMPLY HAD A MEETING
SET UP.
THREE DAYS
BEFORE WE HAD THE MEETING,
WE PUT OUT ON OUR SOCIAL MEDIA,
"HEY, GUYS, IF YOU GET A CHANCE,
PRINT OFF THIS FLIER,
TAKE IT INTO YOUR STORE,
AND JUST REQUEST
O'DANG HUMMUS.
SHOW THEM, YOU KNOW,
'HEY, WE'RE INTERESTED.'"
'CAUSE WE HAD A FAN BASE.
THAT'S PRETTY CLEVER.
VERY CLEVER.
IT IS,
BUT THINGS WENT ROGUE.
UH-OH.
AND THEY TOOK TO FACEBOOK,
AND THEY CRASHED
PUBLIX'S FACEBOOK IN TWO DAYS.
IT WAS KIND OF AWESOME, BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO CALL US AND SAY,
"LISTEN,
WE KNOW YOU'RE COMING."
WE'RE THE ONLY COMPANY
THAT'S EVER LOCKED UP
THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA.
YOU'VE GOT AN ANGLE,
RIGHT?
RIGHT.
AND IT'S A GREAT ANGLE.
THAT BLACK-BEAN STUFF
IS THE [BLEEP]
IT'S GOOD, YOU KNOW?
[ LAUGHS ]
JESSE, WHAT ARE THE NUMBERS
ON THE PUBLIX DEAL?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE IT FOR?
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
OKAY, GREAT.
SO, WE ACTUALLY
WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
THROUGH OUR CO-PACKER
AT THE VERY FIRST RUN FOR $1.25.
WITH SCALE, WE'LL BE ABLE
TO REDUCE THAT DOWN TO 85 CENTS.
WHAT ARE YOU SELLING IT
TO THEM?
WE'RE WHOLESALING IT
FOR $2.25.
SO RIGHT NOW
WE'RE RUNNING A 40% MARGIN.
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
SO, IT'S KIND OF FUNNY.
I'VE BEEN IN COLLEGE
FOR NINE YEARS.
I SHOULD BE A DOCTOR.
YOUR PARENTS MUST BE HAPPY
ABOUT THAT.
THEY ARE THRILLED.
I GOT A FULL-TIME JOB RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF MY COLLEGE CAREER.
WELL, THANK GOD YOU DID.
FOR EIGHT YEARS, THANK GOD
YOU HAD A FULL-TIME JOB.
YEAH, YEAH.
WHAT WAS THE JOB?
I STARTED WORKING FOR AutoZone.
I WAS IN SALES.
I WAS ABLE TO CASH IN
MY 401(k)
THAT I EARNED THERE,
MY STOCK OPTIONS.
I WAS ABLE TO CASH IN
MY SAVINGS.
SO, AND THAT'S WHAT'S KEPT ME,
YOU KNOW,
PAYING MYSELF
FOR THE LAST YEAR.
AND ALL OF IT
WENT INTO THIS?
EVERY --
SO YOU'RE ALL-IN.
HOW MUCH MONEY
DID YOU PUT IN?
ABOUT $40,000.
JESSE,
WHEN DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE GONNA GET THE P.O.
FROM PUBLIX?
I'M REALLY FOCUSED
ON THAT.
THREE WEEKS.
YOU THINK YOU'RE GONNA GET
A PHYSICAL ORDER?
I KNOW
WE'LL GET A PHYSICAL ORDER.
JESSE,
YOU HAVE TO TAKE A BREATH.
SORRY.
YOU TALK
MORE THAN THE SHARKS.
I GET REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT HUMMUS.
NO, I CAN SEE
YOUR ENTHUSIASM.
BUT I HAVE INVESTED
IN SO MANY FOOD BUSINESSES.
YES, MA'AM.
AND THAT'S WHY I LOVE YOU.
I THINK YOU ARE UNDERESTIMATING
WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TO GO INTO
THE BIG-BOX STORES.
IT IS SO EXPENSIVE.
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND.
I MEAN, TRUST ME, I'VE CALLED.
I DON'T TRUST YOU -- 'CAUSE
OF YOUR LACK OF EXPERIENCE.
I REALLY DON'T.
BUT I HAVE NEVER MET
A MORE NAIVE PERSON
STANDING THERE ABOUT TO GO
BIG-TIME INTO THE FOOD SPACE.
SO I'M OUT.
BARBARA, I BEG TO DIFFER,
BECAUSE I'VE SPENT
BLOOD, SWEAT, AND TEARS.
I BELIEVE YOU.
I STOOD OUTSIDE
IN 105-DEGREE WEATHER,
TESTING THIS PRODUCT.
I'M NOT NAIVE TO HOW HARD IT IS
TO GET THIS PRODUCT TO SCALE.
JESSE, SO, I ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE
A FOOD-PRODUCT INVESTMENT.
OH, FANTASTIC.
AND EVERY TIME
I HEAR ABOUT KEVIN'S CUPCAKES
OF ONE OF BARBARA'S SUCCESSES,
IT JUST IRRITATES ME,
'CAUSE
I'M A COMPETITIVE GUY.
RIGHT,
AND I KNOW THAT.
BUT MORE THAN THAT,
I WISH I HAD THE GUY.
I'M THAT GUY.
YOU'RE THAT GUY?
OH, GOD.
IT'S IMPRESSIVE
HOW FAR YOU'VE COME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
I'LL GO $50,000, 15%.
THAT'S A -- WOW. THANK YOU.
THAT IS AN INCREDIBLE OFFER.
REALLY, IT'S AN INVESTMENT
IN YOU.
O'Leary: I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I AM IN THE FOOD BUSINESS.
YES, SIR.
IT'S EXTREMELY HARD.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU THE $50,000
FOR 20%.
I WANT TO GET THREE SKUs
AND PURCHASE ORDERS FROM PUBLIX.
I DON'T WANT YOU
DOING ANYTHING ELSE.
OKAY.
BUT IT'S GONNA COST YOU 20%,
'CAUSE I KNOW A LOT MORE
THAN HE DOES ABOUT
THE FOOD BUSINESS, ALL RIGHT?
YOU'VE GOT TO BE LASER-FOCUSED
ON SUCCESS.
RIGHT.
YOU HAVE TO PROVE OUT THAT
YOU CAN ACTUALLY FULFILL PUBLIX
AND MAINTAIN YOUR SKU
IN THE REFRIGERATED SECTION.
IF YOU CAN PROVE THAT OUT, THEN
YOU CAN ROLL IT TO EVERYBODY.
IT'S REALLY TOUGH.
BUT WE HAVE ACCOUNTED FOR
ALL OF THAT.
I'VE DONE THE HOMEWORK
ON THAT.
$50,000 RIGHT NOW,
OKAY --
IT'S GONNA GET US
AT LEAST THE FIRST TWO RUNS.
Greiner:
IT'S GREAT TO BE PASSIONATE,
BECAUSE PASSION DOES SELL,
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO HAVE
ALL THE RIGHT THINGS.
RIGHT.
LORI,
DO YOU HAVE AN OFFER?
WHAT IF YOU AND LORI
WENT IN TOGETHER
FOR $50,000 FOR 15%?
LOOK, JESSE, I --
I WOULD GO IN WITH ROBERT,
BUT NOT FOR 15%.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE?
$50,000, 25%.
AND WE'LL FUND --
YOU NEED MONEY.
YEAH.
IF WE GET INTO
ALL OF THESE PLACES,
YOU HAVE TO FUND
ALL OF THIS.
OH, OF COURSE. RIGHT.
$50,000, LORI AND I,
FOR 25%.
WOULD YOU DO $50,000
FOR 20%?
AND I'M YOUR GUY.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU KNOW I'M STILL IN,
RIGHT?
OH.
I WOULD DO THAT.
DONE.
DONE!
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU BLEW IT.
AH!
I'M EXCITED.
I WOULD HAVE GIVEN HIM $100K
FOR 25%.
YEAH!
[ LAUGHS ]
I'M SO EXCITED. IT'S GREAT
PARTNERING WITH YOU GUYS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD LUCK, GUY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, GUYS.
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE.
BARBARA,
I STILL LOVE YOU.
[ LAUGHS ]
WHOO, BABY!
YES!
THAT'S HOW IT'S DONE.
IT MEANS THE WORLD.
YOU KNOW, I MEAN,
I QUIT MY JOB, YOU KNOW,
AND [LAUGHS] CASHED IN
MY RETIREMENT AND STUFF,
AND I'VE WORKED SO HARD
TO GET TO THIS VERY POINT.
THERE'S NO BETTER FEELING
ON EARTH. YOU CAN'T BUY THIS.
♪♪
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A SOLUTION
FOR THE DREADED
FORGOTTEN PASSWORD.
[ LAUGHS ]
DRESSED FOR COCKTAILS.
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M DOUG CLARK.
AND I'M CHAD CLARK.
WE'RE BROTHERS.
WE'RE PARTNERS.
AND, APPARENTLY,
WE DRESS THE SAME.
SHARKS,
TODAY IS YOUR LUCKY DAY.
WE'RE WILLING TO BET
YOU HAVE PASSWORD PROBLEMS.
YOU TRY YOUR PASSWORD,
AND IT DOESN'T WORK.
THEN YOU TRY
ADDING YOUR FAVORITE NUMBER
TO THAT GO-TO PASSWORD,
AND IT DOESN'T WORK, EITHER.
YOU END UP HAVING TO
RESET YOUR PASSWORD.
YOU GO THROUGH ALL OF THE STEPS
TO RESET YOUR PASSWORD.
YOU'VE WASTED A TON OF TIME,
AND YOU'RE FRUSTRATED.
BUT NOT ANYMORE,
WITH SPLIKITY.
SPLIKITY IS SOFTWARE THAT RUNS
ACROSS ALL OF YOUR DEVICES.
IT SAVES YOUR PASSWORDS,
IT AUTOMATICALLY FILLS THEM
AS YOU BROWSE THE INTERNET,
AND IT AUTOMATICALLY SYNCS THEM
TO ALL OF YOUR DEVICES
SO YOU HAVE THEM
WHEREVER YOU ARE
AND WHEREVER
YOU NEED THEM MOST.
BUT NOT ONLY THAT,
SPLIKITY CREATES
STRONG, UNIQUE PASSWORDS
FOR ALL OF YOUR ACCOUNTS
TO HELP KEEP PEOPLE SAFE ONLINE.
WITH SPLIKITY,
EVERYTHING IS SIMPLE.
YOU'LL NEVER
HAVE TO REMEMBER
OR EVEN TYPE
ANOTHER PASSWORD AGAIN.
SO, SHARKS, WHO WANTS
TO ATTACK THE PASSWORD PROBLEM
WITH SPLIKITY?
YOU DIDN'T ASK
FOR ANY MONEY.
WE'RE GETTING
TO THAT.
WE'RE ASKING
FOR $200,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
OKAY.
Corcoran:
ARE YOU BOTH TECHIES?
YOU SURE DON'T LOOK THE PART
IN THAT SUIT.
WELL, LET US TELL YOU
ABOUT THE SUITS.
[ LAUGHS ] OKAY.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST INTERVIEW
OF OUR LIVES,
AND WE WANTED
TO LOOK SHARP.
OUR FRIENDS LIKE
TO MAKE FUN OF US A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE WE HAPPEN TO LIVE
AT HOME WITH OUR PARENTS.
YOU SEE, WE ARE PUTTING
EVERYTHING WE HAVE
INTO SPLIKITY.
WHO CAME UP WITH
THE DESIGN?
US AND OUR TEAM DESIGNED
THE SOFTWARE.
WHAT'S
YOUR SECURITY BACKGROUND?
UH, WE DO NOT HAVE
A TECHNOLOGY BACKGROUND.
I'M OUT.
WOW, MARK.
THAT'S NEGATIVE.
SECURITY IS NOT
AN EASY SUBJECT, RIGHT?
YOU DON'T JUST FIGURE OUT
AND SAY,
"OKAY,
I'M GONNA LEARN SECURITY,
AND I'M GONNA TELL
MY PROGRAMMERS WHAT TO WRITE."
MARK, I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND.
SECURITY IS A HUGE SUBJECT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT PEOPLE CAN'T LEARN IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THERE ARE HACKERS OUT THERE
LOOKING AT THAT,
GOING, "YEAH, BOY!"
I UNDERSTAND.
BUT WHAT THE HACKERS DON'T KNOW
IS WE ARE IMPLEMENTING
LEADING SECURITY MEASURES
TO KEEP PEOPLE'S SECURITY --
AND WHERE DO YOU GET
THOSE SECURITY MEASURES FROM?
WE HAVE GUYS
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING IN
THIS INDUSTRY FOR A LONG TIME.
OUR LEAD DEVELOPER --
O'Leary:
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE GREAT
THINGS ABOUT "SHARK TANK"
IS THAT IN EVERY SECTOR,
THERE'S AN EXPERT.
NOW, IN THIS CASE,
MR. HERJAVEC MAKES A LIVING
SELLING SECURITY SYSTEMS
TO REALLY BIG COMPANIES.
AND I HAVE AN APP
CALLED CYBER DUST,
WHERE I'VE HAD TO PAY ATTENTION
TO SECURITY CONTINUOUSLY.
SO BE CAREFUL
WHEN YOU ANSWER THIS,
'CAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE ABOUT TO GET FRIED.
GIVE THEM
A CHANCE!
Doug:
YOU KNOW, MARK,
I'M SURE THAT WHEN YOU STARTED
WITH CYBER DUST,
YOU DIDN'T HAVE
A SECURITY BACKGROUND.
Herjavec: YEAH, BUT IT DOESN'T
WORK THAT WAY, GUYS.
YOU'RE COMING
TO THE TAIL END OF AN INDUSTRY
THAT'S BEEN AROUND
FOR A LONG TIME.
HOW LONG
HAVE PASSWORDS BEEN AROUND?
LIKE, THIS ISN'T
A FLIGHTY SUBJECT.
I'M PREPARING THE BUTTER
TO SAUTé YOU IN IT.
OH, STOP IT! YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU GUYS CAME IN HERE.
YOU CARED ENOUGH ABOUT IT
TO DRESS UP FOR THE MOMENT.
GARLIC OR NO GARLIC,
LORI?
LISTEN, EVERYBODY'S
BITING YOUR HEADS OFF.
TELL US HOW IT WORKS.
THE ENCRYPTED DATA,
WHICH IS USING AES256,
THOUSANDS OF ROUNDS
OF PBKDF2 AND BCRYPT --
THAT'S TYPICAL.
EVERYBODY DOES THAT.
NOT EVERYBODY
DOES THAT, AND --
AES256 IS NOT UNUSUAL.
AES256 IS
A LEADING STANDARD.
BUT IT'S NOT UNIQUE TO YOU.
IT'S OPEN-SOURCE.
IT'S NOT EXCLUSIVE
TO YOU.
SO, KEEP GOING.
I DOWNLOAD THE APP. TELL ME --
SO YOU SAVE
YOUR PASSWORDS.
OKAY.
IT'S ENCRYPTED.
YOU LOG IN WITH OUR APP.
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
I GO TO A WEBSITE.
EVERYTHING IS AUTOMATIC.
THE NEXT TIME
YOU GO TO A WEBSITE,
IT AUTOMATICALLY FILLS
YOUR USERNAME AND PASSWORD,
AUTOMATICALLY
LOGS YOU IN.
OKAY.
Greiner: LET ME COME FROM
THE FEMALE POINT OF VIEW, OKAY?
[ LAUGHS ]
THERE'S A FEMALE POINT OF VIEW
TO TECHNOLOGY?
YOU DON'T USE PASSWORDS?
THERE IS NO FEMALE POINT
OF VIEW.
NO, OF COURSE THERE IS!
OH, MY GOD!
IT'S A TECHNOLOGY
QUESTION.
NO! YOU GUYS!
FROM BEING IN TV SALES
FOR 18 YEARS,
I KNOW THAT WOMEN CONSUMERS
REACT DIFFERENTLY
TO CERTAIN THINGS
THAN MALE CONSUMERS DO.
SO IF YOU'RE NOT A TECHIE WOMAN,
THIS MIGHT BE APPEALING TO YOU.
MAYBE YOU GUYS THINK
IS SUBPAR OR NOTHING NEW,
BUT FOR A WOMAN,
IT WOULD BE EASY TO ACCESS.
LORI, THIS IS CRAZY.
SO I WANT TO HEAR
WHAT THEY HAVE TO SAY ABOUT IT
WITHOUT THEM
GETTING SKEWERED.
I'M SO HAPPY WITH WHAT
LORI JUST SAID, BECAUSE SHE --
I BET YOU ARE,
'CAUSE WE'RE CRUSHING YOU,
AND SHE'S TRYING TO GIVE YOU
A LIFELINE.
YEAH, BUT --
DOUG, SECURITY IS
A NON-GENDER ISSUE.
SECURITY IS
FOR EVERYBODY.
NO, NO.
THAT'S NOT THE POINT
THAT I'M TRYING TO MAKE.
NO, HAVING AN APP
THAT'S USER-FRIENDLY
WELL, WHAT'S THE POINT
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE?
...MAKES A WOMAN
FEEL COMFORTABLE.
LET US ADDRESS IT.
LET ME ADDRESS
WHAT LORI SAID.
HOW MUCH DO YOU CHARGE
FOR THE SERVICE?
NO, NO. LET HIM FINISH, THOUGH,
ROBERT, PLEASE.
LET HIM FINISH. BECAUSE, BARB,
AREN'T YOU INTERESTED?
I'M VERY INTERESTED,
AND I AGREE WITH HER
THAT WE HAVE
A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON IT,
AND I'M ANXIOUS
TO HEAR YOUR ANSWER
IF THE GENTLEMEN WOULD NOT BE
SO RUDE.
AND WE'RE NOT
AS TECHNOLOGICAL.
Herjavec:
WHAT DO YOU CHARGE FOR IT?
IT'S $4.99 A MONTH
OR $49.99 A YEAR.
Corcoran: ONLY ABOUT A WEEK AGO,
I COULDN'T REMEMBER A PASSWORD.
IT WAS DRIVING ME NUTS,
ALL RIGHT?
TOOK ALL OF MY PASSWORDS
AND DUMPED IT INTO ONE APP,
AND ALL I NOW HAVE
IS ONE PASSWORD,
SO IT'S AN AGGREGATE
OF ALL OF MY PASSWORDS.
IS THIS
WHAT THIS SITE DOES?
AND IF SO, AREN'T THERE
A LOT OF THEM OUT THERE?
YES,
AND IT ALLOWS --
SO THERE'S
LOTS OF COMPETITION, RIGHT?
WE ARE THE FIRST SOLUTION
BUILT SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE EVERYDAY,
NONTECHNICAL USER.
Herjavec:
NO, NO. BUT HANG ON, NOW.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
YOU'RE TELLING ME
WHO IT'S DESIGNED FOR.
GOT IT.
BUT TELL ME
WHAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT IT.
JUST GIVE ME THAT SECRET SAUCE.
GIVE ME SOMETHING.
OUR PROPRIETARY BANNER
THAT INTERACTS WITH THE USER
AS THEY BROWSE
THE INTERNET.
BUT YEAH,
THAT'S NOT NEW, RIGHT?
BUT YOU'RE JUST SAYING
IT'S SIMPLER.
YES. AND IT --
TELL ME
WHAT YOUR SALES ARE.
OKAY.
OUR SALES ARE $55,000 SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF LAST MONTH.
THAT'S NOT BAD.
THAT'S GOOD.
SO YOU'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
A MONTH?
WHEN WE WERE
FINISHING DEVELOPMENT
AT THE END OF LAST YEAR,
WE WERE APPROACHED
BY A LARGE SECURITY COMPANY,
WENT THROUGH
ALL OF OUR SOFTWARE,
MADE SURE THAT IT WAS
UP TO THEIR STANDARDS,
AND THEY WANTED
TO LICENSE IT FROM US.
SO THE $55,000
IS A ROYALTY FROM THEM.
YES.
WHICH ONE?
I CAN'T SHARE
THAT INFORMATION.
WE'RE UNDER
NONDISCLOSURE.
HOW MUCH DO THEY PAY YOU
PER USER?
WE CAN'T SAY EXACTLY
HOW MUCH THEY PAY US PER USER.
THAT'S PART OF
THEIR NONDISCLOSURE.
YOU WANT AN INVESTMENT.
GUYS, LET ME GIVE YOU THE ANSWER
THAT YOU'RE GIVING US.
I'M GONNA TURN IT AROUND
FOR A SECOND
SO YOU CAN SEE
WHAT IT FEELS LIKE FROM HERE.
I'M GONNA SELL YOU A PRODUCT.
IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT.
AND I'M GONNA TELL YOU
WHY YOU'RE GONNA THINK
THIS IS
THE BEST PRODUCT EVER --
BECAUSE I LICENSED IT
TO A COMPANY
I CAN'T TELL YOU ABOUT,
BUT THEY'RE A GREAT COMPANY.
I CAN'T TELL YOU THEIR NAME,
I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT THEY DO,
BUT THEY'RE A GREAT COMPANY
IN THIS SPACE,
SO YOU SHOULD BELIEVE ME
AND GIVE ME HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
YOU READY
TO WRITE ME A CHECK?
O'Leary: WE'RE AT THE HALFTIME
OF THE GAME.
HOW'S IT GOING?
♪♪
Narrator:
ONLY ONE SHARK IS OUT,
BUT THINGS DON'T LOOK PROMISING
FOR DOUG AND CHAD'S
ONLINE PASSWORD APP, SPLIKITY.
O'Leary: WE'RE AT THE HALFTIME
OF THE GAME.
HOW'S IT GOING?
[ Laughing ] OH, GOD!
YOU KNOW, HONESTLY --
YOU KNOW, HONESTLY,
WE --
WE ENJOY THE QUESTIONS.
WE DO ENJOY
THE QUESTIONS.
WE'VE HAD
A LOT OF TOUGH QUESTIONS
FROM A LOT OF THE COMPANIES
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO.
WE TOLD YOU WE'VE DONE A DEAL
WITH ONE COMPANY.
WE'RE TALKING
TO SIX OTHER ONES.
Herjavec: CHAD, I WILL GIVE YOU
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
YOU HAVE A CONSUMER BRAND,
AND I RESPECT THAT.
YOU'RE TRYING TO GO AFTER
THE CONSUMER BUSINESS.
I SEE A LOT OF CHALLENGES
FROM A MARKETING PERSPECTIVE.
I'M NOT YOUR INVESTOR.
I KNOW TOO MUCH.
I'M OUT.
TO YOUR POINT, I WISH
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE ASKED US
SOME OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN THE SECURITY AREA.
WE'RE USING AES256.
OKAY.
WE'RE USING TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF ROUNDS OF PBKDF2.
OKAY.
WE'RE USING ALL
THE INDUSTRY-LEADING STANDARDS
FOR ENCRYPTION.
RIGHT, BUT THEY'RE --
BUT YOU JUST SAID
IT'S INDUSTRY-LEADING STANDARDS.
Corcoran:
THIS IS VERY CONFUSING TO ME.
YOU SEEM LIKE NICE GUYS.
BUT I CAN'T GET IT,
AND SO I'M GONNA GO OUT,
SIMPLY BECAUSE MY CHANCES
OF MAKING MONEY ON THIS
ARE NEXT TO ZERO
IF I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
Greiner:
THIS IS A HUGE PROBLEM,
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT CAN USE THIS.
MOST THINGS FOR ME, IF I CAN
UNDERSTAND THEM QUICKLY,
THEN THAT'S GREAT FOR ME
AS A CONSUMER.
BUT BECAUSE I COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT QUICKLY,
I'M SORRY TO SAY
I'M OUT.
IF YOU GUYS
COULD JUST GIVE US TWO MINUTES
TO EXPLAIN
WHAT WE WANTED TO EXPLAIN --
THERE'S ONLY ONE SHARK LEFT.
THAT'S ME.
I ONLY HAVE ONE QUESTION
OF YOU GUYS, OKAY?
I ASKED YOU AT HALFTIME
HOW YOU WERE DOING.
YOU HADN'T EVEN SCORED YET.
NO FIELD GOALS, NOTHING,
ALL RIGHT?
SO -- JUST -- LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT I THINK.
THERE IS A DEMAND
FOR A PRODUCT LIKE THIS.
YEP. FOR SURE.
I AM A HUGE BRAND IN
THE FINANCIAL-SERVICES INDUSTRY.
I SELL O'SHARES,
MY ETF COMPANY.
I SELL O'LEARY FUNDS,
MY MUTUAL FUND COMPANY.
EVERY SINGLE SHARE
IN ALL THOSE FUNDS
IS HELD
ON AN ELECTRONIC BANK
WHERE CONSUMERS GO AND LOOK
AT THEIR ACCOUNTS EVERY DAY
USING PASSWORDS --
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF THEM.
THEY ALL HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM.
I AGREE THERE'S A PROBLEM.
IF YOU'RE TRYING
TO TURN THIS INTO A BRAND,
HERE'S A DEAL
I'LL OFFER YOU, OKAY?
BECAUSE NO ONE ELSE
IS GONNA THROW YOU A LIFELINE.
THE ONLY WAY
I'LL DO THIS IS
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $200,000
AS VENTURE DEBT.
ALL RIGHT?
I LOAN IT TO YOUR COMPANY,
'CAUSE YOU NEED IT
TO ACTUALLY START BUILDING
THIS CONSUMER BRAND.
YOU PAY ME 10% OF SALES
UNTIL YOU PAY ME BACK $600,000.
TO KEEP ME INTERESTED
IN CARING ABOUT YOU
AND ENDORSING YOUR BRAND,
I WANT 5% OF THE COMPANY
JUST BECAUSE I'M MR. WONDERFUL.
I APPRECIATE YOUR OFFER.
I THINK YOU SHOULD, 'CAUSE
YOU DIDN'T GET ANYTHING ELSE.
WHY WOULD YOU
WANT TO PARTNER WITH HIM
AFTER WHAT YOU
JUST SAT THERE --
BECAUSE I CAN ACTUALLY
MAKE THIS WORK FOR YOU.
WE WANT IT TO BE
A CONSUMER BRAND
THAT WENT
DIRECT TO CONSUMER.
DO YOU WANT ME TO HELP YOU
TURN THIS INTO A BRAND OR NOT?
I KNOW MY VALUE. I'M VERY
CONFIDENT IN MY ABILITIES.
I'VE DONE IT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
I'M REALLY GOOD.
BUT I STILL SEE
THE MERIT FOR THE SERVICE.
DO YOU WANT TO DO
MY DEAL OR NOT? YES OR NO?
WE APPRECIATE
YOUR OFFER.
WE'RE GONNA BE PROFITABLE
NEXT MONTH.
WE'RE GOING HOME
TO SIGN ANOTHER DEAL,
AND WE'RE IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH FIVE OTHER COMPANIES.
THIS IS ALL
SINCE LAST MONTH.
IS THAT A YES OR A NO?
[ HERJAVEC LAUGHS ]
♪♪
NO.
I'M OUT.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE JUST GIVEN US
TWO MINUTES -- TWO MINUTES.
THAT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS.
YOU COME INTO THE SHARK TANK.
YOU SHOW WHAT YOU'VE GOT.
Herjavec: DOUG, IT'S NOT
MY RESPONSIBILITY TO LISTEN.
IT'S YOUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO MAKE ME HEAR.
GUYS, IT'S OVER.
THANKS A LOT
FOR YOUR TIME.
Herjavec:
CHAD AND DOUG, GOOD LUCK.
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK.
♪♪
WE WISH THAT WE WOULD HAVE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE BEING ASKED,
AND I THINK THAT ALL
OF THE SHARKS WOULD HAVE
REALLY BEEN IMPRESSED
WITH WHAT WE'RE DOING
AND REALLY SEEN THE VALUE IN IT
IF WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS.
YOU BIT
THEIR HEADS OFF.
I DIDN'T BITE THEIR HEADS OFF.
I GAVE THEM THE OFFER.
ROBERT AND MARK WERE
AT YOUR ALL-TIME RUDENESS.
SHAME ON BOTH OF YOU.
IT WAS NOT RUDE.
YOU WERE REALLY RUDE
TO THEM.
TO THEM?!
Narrator:
IN SEASON 6, WE WATCHED
DIANA AND JOSH HARBOUR
MAKE A DEAL FOR
THEIR ONLINE FASHION BUSINESS,
RED DRESS BOUTIQUE.
$1.2 MILLION FOR 20%.
YES.
DEAL.
Narrator: LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
[ TELEPHONE RINGS ]
THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THE RED DRESS BOUTIQUE.
Diana: WE HAVE LEARNED SO MUCH
IN THE PAST EIGHT MONTHS,
AND WITH MARK'S HELP,
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO TAKE OUR BUSINESS
IN DIRECTIONS
WE COULD HAVE NEVER IMAGINED.
SIX DAYS AFTER "SHARK TANK"
AIRED, WE DID $1 MILLION,
BUT ALL THAT TRAFFIC
CRASHED THE SITE FOR 17 HOURS.
WE WERE LOSING MOMENTUM,
WE WERE LOSING CUSTOMERS.
AND IT SEEMED LIKE A NEW WEBSITE
WAS THE ONLY WAY OUT.
WHEN "BEYOND THE TANK"
CHECKED IN ON US,
WE WENT TO SEE MARK
IN DALLAS.
I'M TERRIFIED OF PUTTING IN
ANY TYPE OF NEW WEBSITE.
YOU'RE WALKING
OUT OF ONE FIRE
INTO ANOTHER ONE THAT COULD
BURN YOUR BUSINESS UP.
IT'S A RISK.
IT'S NOT A SMART RISK.
Diana: HE THOUGHT SPENDING
A QUARTER OF A MILLION DOLLARS
ON A NEW WEBSITE
COULD RISK LOSING EVERYTHING.
THE MORE WE THOUGHT
ABOUT WHAT MARK SAID,
THE MORE WE REALIZED
HE WAS RIGHT,
SO WE DECIDED
TO TAKE HIS ADVICE AFTER ALL.
Hey, guys.
How's it going?
HI, MARK.
The true test
of great entrepreneurs
is how you respond
to adversity.
You guys decided
to come along
and let us
take over the website,
and -- Boom! --
great things have happened.
The gang
is back together.
WE'RE BACK.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS,
LET'S GET THIS OUT.
WE GOT 1,000 MORE
COMING IN.
Josh: OUR SALES AND PROFITS
CONTINUE TO RISE.
IN 2014, WE FINISHED THE YEAR
OVER $14 MILLION IN SALES.
Diana:
WITH THE MONEY WE'VE SAVED
BY NOT GETTING A NEW WEBSITE,
WE'RE DESIGNING OUR FIRST
IN-HOUSE CLOTHING LINE,
WE'RE EXPANDING INTO HOME DECOR,
AND WITH MARK'S HELP,
WE'LL BE LAUNCHING
OUR FIRST RED DRESS APP.
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
FOR THE EXPERIENCE WE'VE HAD
BECAUSE OF "SHARK TANK."
THANKS TO MARK,
THINGS HAVE BEEN BETTER THAN
WE COULD HAVE EVER IMAGINED.
All:
THANK YOU, "SHARK TANK"!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
MY NAME IS MIKKI BEY, I LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA,
AND I'M THE C.E.O.
AT MIKKI BEY EYELASH EXTENSIONS.
COME ON IN, MILAN.
I GOT MY START
AS A CELEBRITY MAKEUP ARTIST
TO STARS LIKE
MISSY ELLIOTT, JASON DERULO,
AND COLBIE CAILLAT.
LET'S GET STARTED.
MY SALON IS PINK.
IT'S GIRLY.
PEOPLE CALL IT
THE BARBIE DREAM HOUSE.
WE'RE A FUN PLACE TO BE.
IT'S A VERY GIRL-FRIENDLY
EXPERIENCE.
MAKE SURE
YOU KEEP YOUR EYES CLOSED.
EYELASH EXTENSIONS
ARE BECOMING MORE POPULAR,
AND WOMEN ARE STARTING
TO ASK QUESTIONS LIKE,
"WHY DO YOU EYES LOOK SO GOOD?"
I'VE DEVELOPED
A PROPRIETARY SYSTEM TO APPLY
THE HIGHEST-QUALITY LASHES
IN THE SHORTEST AMOUNT OF TIME.
I'M THE FIRST TO DO IT,
AND I'M THE BEST.
HOW ARE THINGS GOING
AT THE SALON TODAY?
I'VE PUT EVERYTHING THAT I HAVE
INTO THIS BUSINESS.
IT'S MY BEST FRIEND.
IT'S MY HUSBAND. IT'S MY KIDS.
IT'S MY WHOLE LIFE.
I'M READY TO BUILD
A MIKKI BEY BRAND.
I REALLY SEE US
IN ALL THE LUXURY DESTINATIONS
OF THE WORLD.
AND I KNOW,
WITH A SHARK AS A PARTNER,
WE COULD DO IT
IN THE BLINK OF AN EYE.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M MIKKI BEY.
I'M THE C.E.O.
AND MASTER LASH ARTIST
OF MIKKI BEY EYELASH EXTENSIONS,
LOCATED IN
LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA.
I'M SEEKING $300,000
FOR 20% OF MY BUSINESS.
KIM KARDASHIAN WEST,
BEYONCé, AND J.LO --
YOU KNOW IT'S ALL FAKE, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHS ]
COME ON, GUYS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT
THEIR EYELASHES.
BUT WITH A LITTLE HELP FROM ME,
YOU, TOO, CAN GET
THAT GLAMOROUS CELEBRITY LOOK.
WELCOME TO
MIKKI BEY EYELASH EXTENSIONS.
IF YOU HAVE EYELASHES,
EYELASH EXTENSIONS ARE FOR YOU.
EVEN MEN ARE
JUMPING IN ON THE BANDWAGON.
CAN'T YOU IMAGINE MR. WONDERFUL
IN MIKKI BEY EYELASH EXTENSIONS?
YEAH!
I CAN'T.
BUT, MARK, I CAN'T WAIT
TO GET MY HANDS ON YOU.
BRING IT, BABY.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WHOA!
WITH YOUR CONNECTIONS,
WE'LL BE LAUGHING
ALL THE WAY TO THE BANK.
HOOK ME UP.
YOUR NEXT BEST INVESTMENT
IS ONE WINK AWAY.
YOU READY?
LET'S DO IT.
HOW DO YOU WANT ME?
JUST GO AHEAD
AND LAY DOWN.
[ Laughing ]
"HOW DO YOU WANT ME?"
Herjavec: PLEASE KEEP
YOUR CLOTHES ON, MARK.
OKAY, GO AHEAD
AND CLOSE FOR ME.
OKAY.
SO, I'M JUST TAKING
A LITTLE DAB
OF MEDICAL ADHESIVE GLUE.
I'M GOING TO SEPARATE
ONE OF HIS LASHES
SO THAT IT'S ISOLATED
BY ITSELF.
WOW.
AND THEN
I'LL JUST ATTACH THE LASH.
DID YOU JUST PUT IT ON?
YES.
SO, THIS IS YOUR LASH.
THIS IS THE EYELASH EXTENSION.
IT'S FLUSH TO YOUR LASH
AND NOT YOUR SKIN.
HOW MANY LASHES
DID YOU PUT ON HIS EYE?
I JUST PUT ON ONE
BECAUSE I'M GONNA HAVE
TO TAKE IT OFF OF HIM.
THAT'S ALL?
HOW CAN WE TELL HOW GOOD IT IS?
WELL, WE HAVE MODELS.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE
BEFORE-AND-AFTERS.
Herjavec: OH, I CAN SEE.
Greiner:
OKAY, YEAH. LET'S SEE THAT.
Bey: THE BEST THING
ABOUT EYELASH EXTENSIONS
IS THAT IT CUTS
YOUR MAKEUP TIME IN HALF, SO --
OKAY, MIKKI,
THERE'S NOTHING UNIQUE
ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE DOING HERE.
WELL, IS THERE?
YOU'RE GOOD AT IT.
THERE IS.
WHAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT IT?
I HAVE A TECHNIQUE
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO PATENT,
AND I'VE BEEN ABLE TO CUT THE
APPLICATION TIME DOWN IN HALF.
AND WHY CAN YOU DO IT
IN HALF THE TIME?
I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT,
BECAUSE --
THAT'S HER PATENT.
EXACTLY.
O'Leary: WAIT A SECOND.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR AN INVESTOR.
YOU'RE TELLING ME
THAT THIS IS WORTH $1.5 MILLION.
YES, SIR.
WHAT DO YOU DO
THAT'S WORTH $1.5 MILLION?
LET'S GET SERIOUS HERE,
'CAUSE I'M REALLY THINKING,
WHAT?
WELL, MY REVENUE IN 2012
WAS $69,000.
MY REVENUE IN 2013
WAS $95,000.
NOTHING WRONG
WITH THAT BUSINESS,
BUT WHY IS IT WORTH
$1.5 MILLION?
SURE.
I'M GONNA GET TO IT.
WHILE
WE'RE STILL ALIVE HERE.
YEAH, I'M GONNA TAKE MY TIME.
THIS IS MY MOMENT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU GO, GIRL.
ALL RIGHT!
[ LAUGHTER ]
UM...
IN 2014,
WE MADE $130,000,
AND YEAR-TO-DATE RIGHT NOW,
WE ARE AT ABOUT $60,000.
AND I HAVE JUST ADDED
FULL STAFF.
I HAVE FOUR OTHER
PART-TIME LASH ARTISTS.
BUT, MIKKI,
WHAT AM I BUYING?
AM I BUYING A SERVICE,
OR AM I BUYING
A PROPRIETARY PRODUCT?
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO USE THE
MONEY FOR DEFINITELY IS PRODUCT,
AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I HAVE TO HAVE
IS MY OWN MIKKI BEY
EYELASH EXTENSIONS BRAND,
BECAUSE I PLAN
TO LICENSE THIS.
I HAVE A WAY
THAT I ASSEMBLE THE LASHES
SO THAT IT'S MUCH EASIER
AS FAR AS THE SIZE
TO GET IT ON THE LASHES
FASTER.
THAT SOUNDS GOOD, BUT WHY CAN'T
ANYBODY ELSE DO THAT, MIKKI?
THEY COULD.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY'RE TRYING TO REPLICATE
SOMETHING I CREATED.
OKAY, THEY COULD.
I'M ALWAYS GONNA BE
AHEAD OF THE TREND.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH YOUR BUSINESS -- NOTHING.
YOU KNOW HOW TO DO SOMETHING
VERY, VERY WELL,
AND PEOPLE ARE WILLING
TO PAY A LOT OF MONEY FOR IT.
BUT THERE'S NOTHING UNIQUE
OR PROPRIETARY ABOUT IT AT ALL.
THERE'S NOWHERE FOR AN INVESTOR
TO FIT INTO THIS STORY.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO
WITH MY $300,000?
WHAT'S THE PLAN?
I'M GOING TO BUY MY PRODUCT,
I'M GOING TO GET MY PATENT,
I'M GOING TO BUILD A TEAM TO
HELP ME GO OUT TO THESE PLACES
AND TRAIN THEM ON-SITE
WITH THEIR AESTHETICIANS
THAT THEY'RE ALREADY PAYING
ON THEIR PAYROLL.
HOW BIG
IS YOUR TEAM NOW?
WE HAVE SIX PEOPLE
WORKING FOR US.
DO YOU HAVE A RETAIL STOREFRONT
RIGHT NOW?
YES, I DO.
A RETAIL STORE?
IT'S ON ONE OF THE BUSIEST
STREETS IN LOS ANGELES, YES.
MIKKI,
WHAT DO YOU CHARGE?
I AM -- I CHARGE $200
FOR THE INITIAL FULL SET.
AND WHAT'S THE SALES
IN THAT RETAIL STORE?
THE YEAR-TO-DATE RIGHT NOW
IS ALMOST $60,000.
THOSE NUMBERS DON'T SUPPORT
A $1.5 MILLION VALUE.
I HAVEN'T HEARD --
I UNDERSTAND THAT,
AND I KNOW THAT IT'S HARD
BUT HANG ON -- LOOK --
FOR AN INVESTOR
TO GET THEIR HEAD AROUND
JUST INVESTING
IN A PERSON
WHO'S TELLING YOU
THEY KNOW WHAT TO DO.
I'VE LISTENED
TO WHAT YOU'VE HAD TO SAY.
BUT YOU HAVEN'T,
BECAUSE I NEED TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT I AM AN EXPERT
IN THIS AREA.
I GOT IT.
IT IS NOT SOMETHING
YOU CAN JUST THROW MONEY AT.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOUR BUSINESS?
YOU'RE DOING OKAY.
YEAH, THAT'S THE POINT.
IT'S JUST THAT
IT'S NOT INVESTABLE.
IT'S JUST NOT INVESTABLE.
IT'S VERY INVESTABLE.
OKAY?
HOW?
BUT IT'S GONNA TAKE SOMEONE
WHO HAS THE VISION TO SEE.
HERE'S MY PREDICTION
FOR YOU, MIKKI --
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET A DEAL
TODAY ON "SHARK TANK."
OKAY.
AND I'M THE FIRST TO TELL YOU
THAT, AND I'M ALWAYS RIGHT.
I'M OUT.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME
BECAUSE...
[ Voice breaking ] I HAVE
GIVEN UP EVERYTHING FOR THIS.
AND EYELASH EXTENSIONS
MAY NOT SOUND IMPORTANT TO YOU,
BUT I HAVE PEOPLE
WHO COME AND SEE ME,
AND IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE
TO THEM.
IT GIVES THEM
MORE CONFIDENCE.
THEY FEEL BETTER
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
I DON'T NEED SOMEONE
TO HOLD MY HAND.
I CAN DO THIS.
I HAVE DONE THIS BY MYSELF.
I'M NOT STOPPING.
THIS IS MY PASSION.
THIS IS MY DESTINY.
I'M SUPPOSED TO BE HERE.
I KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT
TO INVEST IN A PERSON,
BUT I'M ASKING YOU
TO TAKE THE CHANCE ON ME.
TAKE THE CHANCE ON ME,
BECAUSE I PROMISE YOU,
IF I HAVE TO WORK MY FINGERS
TO THE BONE
TO GET YOU YOUR MONEY BACK,
I WILL GET YOU
EVERY PENNY OF YOUR MONEY BACK.
MARK, I AM
A SUPER FAN OF YOU,
AND I ALWAYS SAID
IF I CAN'T GET MARK CUBAN,
I HAVE TO BE MARK CUBAN.
BECAUSE I HAVE THE SAME THING
THAT'S IN ALL OF YOU IN ME.
AND YOU SHOULD RECOGNIZE ME,
'CAUSE I'M YOUR PEOPLE.
WE'RE THE SAME.
I JUST NEED A CHANCE.
MIKKI,
I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW, WHEN I STARTED
MY BROKERAGE BUSINESS,
I THOUGHT
I WAS A BUSINESS.
I RENTED APARTMENTS
AND MADE A COMMISSION CHECK
UNTIL ONE DAY, I REALIZED
I DIDN'T HAVE A BUSINESS.
I HAD A SERVICE.
AND I ACTUALLY SEE YOU
AT THAT POINT HERE.
YOU SHOULD BE THINKING, "HOW
DOES THIS THING GET BUILT BIG
WITHOUT ME,
WITH ME MOTIVATING PEOPLE?"
'CAUSE IT WASN'T UNTIL I DID
THAT AND STEPPED OUT OF SALES
THAT I STARTED BUILDING
A BUSINESS.
I'M OUT, 'CAUSE I SEE IT
AS A SERVICE, NOT A BUSINESS.
THANK YOU.
Greiner: MIKKI.
RIGHT NOW I AGREE WITH BARB.
IT'S A SERVICE.
I DON'T SEE WHAT THERE IS
FOR ME TO INVEST IN.
BUT YOU HAVE A FIRE IN YOU
AND A DRIVE IN YOU
THAT WILL GET YOU
EXACTLY WHERE YOU WANT TO GO.
SO I'M OUT,
BUT I THINK THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU.
Cuban: YOU SAY
YOU HAVE SIX PROFESSIONAL...
TECHNICIANS.
...TECHNICIANS
THAT WORK FOR YOU.
RIGHT.
HOW MUCH ARE YOU POCKETING
PER WEEK?
IT'S ABOUT...
$2,000.
SO IF YOU GO FROM 6 TO 12,
YOU'RE MAKING $4,000 A WEEK.
YOU GO FROM 12 TO 24,
YOU'RE PROBABLY MAKING $8,000.
AND IF SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE
ARE TRAINING OTHER PEOPLE,
NEXT THING YOU KNOW, THERE'S
200 MIKKI BEY TECHNICIANS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
AND YOU'RE DOMINATING
A SPACE.
OKAY.
YOU DON'T NEED ME,
SO I'M OUT,
BUT I JUST THINK
IT'S RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOU.
YOU JUST GOT TO GRAB IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UH, MIKKI, YOU'RE NEVER
GONNA BE A MARK CUBAN.
YOU CAN BE MIKKI BEY.
[ LAUGHS ]
AS MARK SAID,
YOU'RE MAKING GOOD MONEY
DOING WHAT YOU'RE DOING
TODAY,
BUT IT'S JUST NOT SCALABLE
AS AN INVESTMENT.
I'M OUT. THANK YOU.
I LOVE THE EMOTION,
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE UP
THIS CRYING STUFF.
OKAY.
THE MINUTE A WOMAN CRIES,
YOU'RE GIVING AWAY YOUR POWER.
YOU HAVE TO CRY
PRIVATELY.
WELL, I THINK
IT TAKES A LOT OF STRENGTH
TO SHOW
THIS TYPE OF VULNERABILITY.
NO, NO, NO.
I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU MEAN.
NOT IN BUSINESS.
I'M SORRY -- NOT IN BUSINESS.
I HAVE HIRED MEN, WOMEN
MY WHOLE LIFE.
WHEN I GET A WOMAN
WHO'S CRYING,
I RE-FILE HER IN MY HEAD
IN TERMS OF POTENTIAL,
BECAUSE
I DON'T TRUST HER
IN TERMS OF
KEEPING A CAP ON HER EMOTION.
I THINK
IT DEPENDS ON THE PERSON.
IT'S WHAT YOU FELT
IN THE MOMENT, AND IT'S OKAY.
YOU HAVE TO BE
WHO YOU ARE.
NO.
I SAY
SAY GOODBYE TO THE CRYING.
ANYWAYS, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME, MIKKI.
THANK YOU.
COME ON, GIRLS.
LET'S GO.
AH!
THERE SHE GOES.
I DON'T AGREE WITH BARBARA'S
POINT OF VIEW ABOUT CRYING,
BECAUSE IT'S INDICATIVE
OF WHO I AM.
I AM VERY PASSIONATE.
I'M AN ALL-OR-NOTHING
TYPE OF PERSON,
SO I LEFT IT ALL OUT THERE.
PEOPLE ARE PEOPLE. YOU CAN'T
MAKE BLANKET STATEMENTS.
YEAH.
YES, YOU CAN.
DON'T CRY FOR MONEY.
IT NEVER CRIES FOR YOU.
♪♪
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A UNIQUE WAY
TO REDUCE THE USE
OF DISPOSABLE TABLEWARE.
HI. I'M CHELSEA.
AND I'M LEIGH ANN.
WE'RE FROM NEW YORK CITY,
AND WE'RE SEEKING $150,000
FOR 10% OF OUR COMPANY,
LOLIWARE.
LOLIWARE IS
A NEW CATEGORY
OF SUSTAINABLE MATERIALS
THAT YOU CAN EAT.
THAT'S RIGHT --
I JUST ATE MY CUP.
THAT'S FUNNY.
WE CALL THIS NEW CATEGORY
BIODEGREDIBLE.
IT'S BOTH BIODEGRADABLE
AND EDIBLE.
IT'S A NEW AND EXCITING
EATING AND DRINKING EXPERIENCE
THAT OFFERS
FUN FLAVOR COMBINATIONS
FOR BOTH BEVERAGES
AND DESSERTS.
IMAGINE DRINKING
YOUR COLD-BREW COFFEE
IN OUR MADAGASCAR
VANILLA CUP
OR EVEN A MARGARITA
IN A CITRUS CUP.
LOLIWARE IS
A DELICIOUS ALTERNATIVE
TO DISPOSABLE CUPS
DESTINED FOR THE LANDFILL.
OUR CUPS GO FROM CUP TO SOIL
IN 60 DAYS.
THEY'RE 100% VEGAN,
GLUTEN-FREE,
AND MADE
WITH ORGANIC INGREDIENTS.
BUT THE CUP
IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
WITH LOLIWARE, WE'RE CREATING
A PLASTIC-FREE REVOLUTION
AND GIVING PEOPLE
A REASON
TO GET EXCITED
ABOUT SUSTAINABILITY.
SHARKS, WE INVITE YOU
TO EAT YOUR CUP
AND TO CREATE A BIODEGREDIBLE
WORLD WITH LOLIWARE.
NOW, WHO'S READY TO TRY
THE CUP OF THE FUTURE?
Herjavec:
GOT TO TRY IT.
OKAY.
LORI, WHAT FLAVOR
DO YOU WANT?
OH, WOW.
ROBERT, WE MADE YOU
A SPECIAL MATCHA GREEN TEA FLOAT
WITH CHAMPAGNE
AND GOJI BERRY GARNISH.
THANK YOU.
LORI, WE MADE YOU
A BEAUTIFUL LAVENDER HONEY.
MR. WONDERFUL,
WE MADE YOU
A BEAUTIFUL
TART CHERRY CUP.
IT UPSETS ME EVERY TIME
YOU SAY "MR. WONDERFUL."
THIS ONE RIGHT HERE?
IT UPSETS ME.
YES.
THANK YOU.
I SHOULD
PROBABLY EAT BARBARA'S,
'CAUSE I EAT HER ALIVE
EVERY DAY.
BARBARA, WE HAD TO MAKE YOU
A MADAGASCAR VANILLA CUP
TO PUT AN EDIBLE GOLD RIM
ON IT.
OH, THAT'S GOOD,
WHATEVER'S IN HERE.
Greiner:
YOUR CUP IS DELICIOUS.
WE'RE GLAD YOU LIKE IT.
THIS CUP
IS REALLY DELICIOUS.
I MEAN, I COULD SEE SOMEBODY
EATING YOUR CUP AS A DESSERT.
WHAT IS IT MADE OF?
IT'S A VEGETABLE GELATIN,
SO IT'S AN ALL-VEGAN VERSION
OF GELATIN.
YEAH.
IT'S 100% GLUTEN-FREE.
IT TASTES A LITTLE BIT
LIKE LICORICE, LIKE A --
YAHOO! FOOD
WROTE ABOUT US,
AND THEY THOUGHT THE CUP
WAS LIKE AN ADULT FRUIT ROLL-UP.
ALL OF OUR FLAVORS AND COLORS
COME FROM FRUITS AND VEGETABLES.
WHO IS YOUR CONSUMER
SO FAR?
SO, WE LAUNCHED SALES
THREE MONTHS AGO,
AND WE HAVE $110,000
IN SALES,
AND WE'RE PARTNERING
WITH A $30 MILLION
EVENT-PLANNING COMPANY
IN NEW YORK CITY
CALLED SAVE THE DATE,
WHO HAS JUST SIGNED
A $1.3 MILLION
LETTER OF INTENT
TO SELL LOLIWARE TO ALL OF
THEIR EVENTS IN NEW YORK CITY.
WE ALSO ARE SIGNED
WITH ONE OF THE LARGEST
FOOD-DISTRIBUTION COMPANIES.
Corcoran:
THEY JUST CALLED YOU UP
AND SAID, "WE LOVE YOU.
WE HEARD ABOUT YOU.
WE'RE COMING"?
THEY SAW US
AT A TRADE SHOW.
WE WERE AT CATERSOURCE
IN LAS VEGAS.
I SEE.
IN ONE DAY,
WE SOLD 3,500 CUPS.
WOW.
HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THIS IDEA?
YEAH,
SO, LEIGH ANN AND I MET
AT ONE OF THE TOP DESIGN SCHOOLS
IN NEW YORK CITY,
CALLED PARSONS SCHOOL
OF DESIGN.
MM-HMM.
AND WE GRADUATED
AT THE TOP OF OUR CLASS.
SO, ACTUALLY, THIS PRODUCT
STARTED AS A COMPETITION.
WE THOUGHT,
"WOULDN'T IT BE COOL
IF WE THOUGHT OF JELLO
AS A MATERIAL
THAT WE COULD ACTUALLY CREATE
SOMETHING STRUCTURAL FROM?"
WE THOUGHT, "I WONDER
IF WE COULD REPLACE PLASTIC CUPS
BY MAKING EDIBLE CUPS."
WE WENT TO THE COMPETITION.
EVERYONE LOVED IT.
THEY HAD TO CREATE
A NEW CATEGORY FOR US.
AND SOMETHING INCREDIBLE
HAPPENED.
LOLIWARE EXPLODED
ON THE INTERNET,
AND IT WENT VIRAL.
THE NEXT WEEK,
I GOT AN ORDER FOR 60,000 CUPS
FROM PERNOD RICARD.
60,000 CUPS?
60,000.
Herjavec: AND, CHELSEA,
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR,
AND WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
SO, IT COSTS US 97 CENTS
TO MAKE EACH CUP RIGHT NOW,
AND WE'RE SELLING IT TO
FOOD SERVICE FOR $1.50 PER CUP,
AND WE'RE LOOKING
TO TAKE THOSE COSTS DOWN
DRAMATICALLY
OVER THE NEXT YEAR.
WE ANTICIPATE
THAT IT'LL GO DOWN TO 50 CENTS.
YOU MUST HAVE
RAISED MONEY,
BECAUSE YOU HAD TO PAY
FOR INVENTORY,
YOU HAD TO FIGURE OUT
THE MACHINE.
YEAH, AFTER WE REALIZED THIS IS
SOMETHING WE WANT TO TAKE
FROM PROTOTYPE TO BUSINESS,
WE PUT IN OUR OWN MONEY --
ABOUT $10,000 --
THEN WE DID
A FRIENDS AND FAMILY $100,000,
AND CURRENTLY,
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A $1 MILLION RAISE.
WE'RE 30% THROUGH.
WE HAVE ANOTHER $100,000
COMMITTED.
CHELSEA, LOOK,
I-I LOVE IT.
I THINK
YOU NEED MORE MONEY.
I'M REALLY NOT INTERESTED IN
PUTTING UP THE $150,000 FOR 10%.
YOU HAVE AN OUTSTANDING AMOUNT
OF $600,000.
UM...
I WANT TO PARTICIPATE.
I MEAN, I'D BE INTERESTED
FOR GETTING MORE EQUITY.
SURE. WHAT'S --
IF WE PUT UP
THE ENTIRE $600,000.
YEAH.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO PUT IT UP
ON MY OWN.
I MEAN, I'M HAPPY TO GO IN
WITH ANYBODY ELSE.
WE WOULD LOVE TO CLOSE OUT
THE ROUND WITH THE SHARKS.
HOW MUCH IS LEFT
IN THE ROUND?
$600,000.
WE COULD DO 25%.
CHELSEA, LOOK, I --
Cuban: DONE.
DONE.
YEAH, MARK,
CAN I GET IN ON THAT?
WHO'S COMING IN?
I'M IN.
I WANT A PIECE OF THAT.
CAN WE HEAR OTHER DEALS?
BARBARA?
LET ME DECIDE
WHO GETS IN.
WAIT.
NO!
CHELSEA,
IT WAS MY IDEA.
♪♪
Narrator: WITH ROBERT'S INTEREST
IN OFFERING MORE MONEY
THAN THEY WERE
INITIALLY SEEKING,
LEIGH ANN AND CHELSEA
HAVE REVISED THEIR OFFER
FOR THEIR EDIBLE-CUP COMPANY,
LOLIWARE.
WE WOULD LOVE TO CLOSE OUT
THE ROUND WITH THE SHARKS.
HOW MUCH IS LEFT
IN THE ROUND?
Tucker: $600,000.
WE COULD DO 25%.
DONE. DONE.
YEAH, MARK,
CAN I GET IN ON THAT?
WHO'S COMING IN?
I'M IN.
I WANT A PIECE OF THAT.
CAN WE HEAR OTHER DEALS?
BARBARA?
LET ME DECIDE
WHO GETS IN.
WAIT.
NO!
CHELSEA, IT WAS MY IDEA.
YEAH, IT WAS YOUR IDEA. SO, WHAT
DO WE HAVE ON THE TABLE?
WE WANT TO HEAR.
I'LL GO IN --
I'LL TAKE $200,000 OF IT.
I DID A GREAT INVESTMENT
WITH MARK FOR LOLLACUP.
I DON'T THINK WE NEED
MORE THAN TWO PEOPLE.
NO, WE'RE FINE.
STRAIGHT-UP EQUITY.
NO, NO. BEFORE YOU GO THERE,
CAN I SAY SOMETHING?
ARE YOU IN?
WELL, WE'D LOVE TO HEAR
WHAT BARBARA HAS TO SAY.
NO, I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY SOMETHING.
I PREFER MARK AS A PARTNER
BECAUSE HE HAS GOT
THREE TIMES AS MUCH MONEY THAN
ALL THE OTHER LITTLE MEN HERE.
I'VE DONE VERY WELL
WITH MARK,
EVEN THOUGH
WE SOMETIMES FIGHT ON HERE.
YES.
WE HAVE
A REAL OFFER --
$600,000 FOR 25%.
DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
Corcoran:
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS,
I'D BE HAPPY
TO TAKE MY MOST FAVORITE PARTNER
IN ON THE DEAL
OR EVEN LORI, OKAY?
BUT YOU'D BE
OUT OF YOUR MIND
TO DO A DEAL
WITHOUT ME INVOLVED.
YOU'D REALLY BE CRAZY.
WHY IS THAT?
I AM THE BEST PARTNER
YOU WILL EVER MEET,
AND IF YOU WERE
TO WALK OUT IN THAT HALL
AND CALL ANY OF
MY ENTREPRENEUR PARTNERS --
KEEP ME IN THE DEAL,
AND YOU PICK THE OTHER PARTNERS.
YOU KNOW, WE ALL HAVE
GREAT ENTREPRENEURS.
YOU MUST KNOW THAT
BY NOW.
MR. WONDERFUL, WHAT ARE
YOU THINKING? ARE YOU IN?
YOU KNOW, I'M WILLING TO PARTNER
WITH OTHER SHARKS,
BUT I'VE GOT TO HAVE
ENOUGH TO CARE.
OKAY.
SO I NEED
$200,000 OF THE DEAL.
I'LL GO IN WITH MARK
FOR $600,000 FOR 25%.
WE'RE SHARING THE DEAL.
O'Leary: ALL RIGHT, BUT LOOK,
IF YOU WANT TWO SHARKS,
I'LL GO IN WITH ROBERT,
I'LL DO THE $300,000,
WE'LL TAKE THE WHOLE 25%.
OKAY.
Greiner: I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT I'M THINKING.
OKAY.
I LOVE YOUR MISSION ABOUT CARING
ABOUT WASTE AND LANDFILLS,
BUT I THINK
IT'S REALLY A PARTY THING.
COME IN WITH US, AND WE'LL GET
THREE SHARKS FOR $600K.
THEN IT'S THREE VERSUS TWO.
I LIKE IT.
NO,
I DON'T FEEL LIKE THAT.
AS MUCH AS I LOVE YOU...
I'M GONNA GO OUT.
Both:
WE RESPECT YOUR DECISION.
MARK, ARE YOU THROWING ME
TO THE CURB WITH BARBARA?
HONESTLY,
I CAN WORK WITH EITHER/OR.
I KNOW
IT'S THE SHARK TANK,
BUT I'M NOT GONNA THROW MARK
TO THE CURB.
THE ORIGINAL DEAL WAS MARK AND I
FOR $600,000 FOR 25%.
THAT'S THE OFFER
WE MADE YOU.
OKAY.
I DON'T WANT TO GO IN
WITH KEVIN OR BARBARA.
THAT WAS
THE ORIGINAL OFFER.
OKAY.
O'Leary:
SO, LADIES, AFTER ALL THAT,
YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS.
YOU'VE GOT MARK AND BARBARA --
$600,000 FOR 25% --
OR YOU HAVE MARK AND ROBERT --
$600,000 FOR 25%.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
♪♪
YES.
SO, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL OF THE OFFERS,
MR. WONDERFUL, ROBERT.
UM, WE WOULD LOVE
TO ACCEPT MARK AND BARBARA
TERRIFIC. MM-HMM!
AS OUR TEAM LOLIWARE.
Cuban: GOOD JOB, GUYS.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WOW.
YEAH.
THIS STUFF IS AWESOME.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
TOUGH.
OH, MY GOSH. I CAN'T BELIEVE
WHAT JUST HAPPENED.
Briganti:
THIS IS A REALLY SURREAL MOMENT
FOR LEIGH ANN AND I.
WE WENT IN
ASKING FOR $150,000 FOR 10%,
AND WE WERE EXPECTING TO HAVE TO
OFFER A LOT MORE EQUITY
FOR THAT AMOUNT,
'CAUSE WE'RE A VERY NEW COMPANY.
AND THE FACT
THAT WE'RE WALKING OUT
WITH OUR WHOLE ROUND FINISHED
BY OUR TOP TWO SHARKS,
IT'S REALLY SURREAL.
WE COULDN'T BE
MORE EXCITED.